well I don't think I like that we're in
the race the one I failed yesterday
hopefully I can actually win it this
time
but that guy took a short cut that
[ __ ] took a short cut
hey that's not a lot [ __ ] shut up unless
it's your mama I wouldn't accept your
mom as a tree
nice try [ __ ] is back in the lead you
got two minutes up in this I don't know
if I what the [ __ ] are you doing that
was not a toy
stop talking nipple twisting me I'll
never twist you back right nipple I
never kiss your mama that's right she
like that oh [ __ ] we gotta go all the
way this race last for [ __ ] ever whoa
it went right inside that that sounded
weird oh no I tapped out
whoa we're almost there we're almost
there
we're all I'm saying all of that baby
how about that baby go baby Jim well
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] yes yes what
you say but anyway yeah yeah more bike
talk I'll meet you guys later
really nice lip gloss yeah nice really
[Music]
simple excuse me [ __ ] but I think you
forgot something
what the [ __ ] is a dog doing dog what do
you want what the [ __ ] do you want
Oh what are you guys doing okay we got a
new quest which one do you want me to
pick there's so many of them to pick
which one do you want me to pick the one
in the center you are always together
picking all the ways dog won well we
stole his girlfriend for no good reason
at all our character doesn't even like
her I don't understand this game
something like okay sorry that was the
song I wrote yesterday it's called I
sure I'll do that
sure sorry that was a lie I shouldn't
lie to your breath alright alright
alright here it is finally we're under
the bridge alright let's see what this
[ __ ] has to say ten tournaments that
tournament
ten tournament timmi timmi was more once
more hey good-looking what's up oh
you're so angry but I think you've got a
softer side haven't you caused enough
trouble that's not fair I'm a nice girl
I'm nice to everyone no you're not look
I'm sorry well okay but now Johnny and
his boys won't even speak to me boys can
get really jealous when they find out
you've been kissing another boy was it
like that I'm not like that
okay I left all my things in the
abandoned tenements where they hang out
my address book my keys my perfume my
lipstick no even my laundry everything
no I've got nothing I don't have much
money that's too bad maybe you could get
them back for me you want me to steal
your stuff back from a bloodthirsty mob
of angry Greaseballs
I'd be very grateful Jimmy very grateful
oh she will let me motorboat I'm doing
it can't say no to MOBA about
I don't look at me like I all right so I
guess we go into this [ __ ] house slab
Oh mate
it's my favorite type of meat the one
that you'd slab on 36 a nail that you
jump over here yep hello like that oh
yeah that was how are you tonight I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I
don't think that would work
hey hey come on you're tense
oh [ __ ] I got the cops yeah I got the
cops over me
got better thing stop sliding oh no no
all right it looks like we have to go to
English class oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] not
English guys I'm not like anything news
tie dress demands that you do these
vocabulary assignments what more
freetime
the [ __ ] does he breathe all right here
we go for us bear in mind I'm not
American all right we got we got we got
Lowell I'm afraid that's not English
well if we got low good and we got mo
that's right and we got mo try again
James we we don't count words that's
short I said I got a car
Oh shadow didn't pause ah
idara oh [ __ ] there's no way I'm gonna
finish this one but there's so many more
no don't worry James it was just a
natural consequence of trying why do I
even try on these I suck at English
obviously Jesus all right I want to add
my new hat I know I had a cowboy omelet
this one yes it's beautiful I always
wanted to have the Eiffel Tower on my
head I'm gonna get so many ladies with
it hat jaysis cries at the pimp at all
right we're finally here at the girl's
house or whatever where is it here
we're going in all right stealth mission
collect Lola what a dumb Jesus how can
anyone live there are you [ __ ]
serious
it's very spacious at least I mean Oh
like they have so many sharks I always
want to have like at least bothered it's
a guy that say hello to my little friend
are you doctor you're darker than my
rocket
are you bet to stay that I like the
music it's chill alright nice face okay
hey hey are you Donny
boom Shakalaka what's up you find the
calm in your hair it's okay alright
there's the one in here
find a way to knock down the walls how
about just [ __ ] knocking them up oh
that's not working parents is running
out of ideas right hey don't really know
all right let's go upstairs and shoot
more people because that's what do we do
because I have a knife hey friends stop
ducking it's not cool if you duck
nutball shot nephal bang fight fight
that's right all right all right pin
strikes again all right
I'm gonna smoke your blood you're gonna
smoke my butt with your boot that sounds
like a great idea
these guys really suck
huh [ __ ] mi find a way to not head
whoa jump-scare behind me no don't try
don't try I got the bag of laundry you
got a [ __ ] sledgehammer taking out
the trash I'm just wearing my Eiffel
Tower
no all right we need that hammer
obviously I just love yeah me too
oh [ __ ] bus battle oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] why
does it need a Mon him
I want that badass hammer stomach I love
what you done by the place I especially
love that pile of shares you got over
there would you care to play a game of
chess with me I guess not
I guess you hate chance I can you I can
anyone hey check Hey
all right he's almost out almost now
that hammer is [ __ ] mine that [ __ ]
hammer is mine oh hey babe I don't know
why by amiss is suitable thanks bye why
not
why the [ __ ] not I thought this was what
this piece of [ __ ] was for and there
they are
where's their underwear she [ __ ] lied
to me
I wouldn't it never oh wait there's one
left thank God thank heavens
what is this behind us my hammer no not
by my mouth what is this another one for
the collection right am i coming in
alright now you know what
I [ __ ] their girl hey
what's up never gonna give you up never
gonna let you down never gonna run
around with my skateboard gonna try to
escape better than were true good that
was a really bad song I'm sorry about
that
all right we're going back to finish off
this [ __ ] [ __ ] literally it's
motorboating time it's motorboating
[ __ ] motor body that was really
good
all right here's Lola what up girl I got
to stop riding my butt I know I'm the
best
I gave me some of that food it's mine
[Music]
it's more where that came from
all right we're gonna get lick no I'm
not gonna help you
[Music]
they're rumba let's start that oh there
he is my hero what's you problem now if
you really cared about me you'd fight
for me first of all I'm not sure I
really care about and second we had
fights for me gourd fights for me Jonny
well he certainly fights for me so
there's gonna be a big fight a
winner-take-all sort of thing yes
everyone's involved apart from you I'm
Helen of Troy and you're more interested
in boys called Troy whatever see you
later
I am probably more interested in boys
called Troy honestly I just want money
look around for peanut
[Music]
well it says he's here on the mat so
that [ __ ] got a bike come on I don't
have a bike that's not fair
tell me what Johnny is so I can finish I
know
[Music]
you want something - huh you want
something
[Music]
that's that now you tell me why [ __ ] who
won me Jimmy Hopkins
that's no yay who won who won you yeah
hello that's right ladies
me I'm the daddy now you treacherous
little snake you think you're tough huh
yay you don't need any more of this
Johnny you laugh at me
you turn on me you get it on with that
harlot who I I love I [ __ ] your latter
night Troy are you all right calm down
man it's cool you lost no big deal we
can all be friends you're done kid
finished now I love that poker wave well
what's a door and actually hard
that's [ __ ] I said I gotta run from
the cops now with the flat out back
there but bloody brother guards roadie
from the county bloody from the Costello
[Music]
probably from the car driving running
high only from the car actually not
running now I'm basically
[Applause]
never twice nipple twisting goes that's
right what am I doing here Harry but
it's never twice Naha never twice that
oh shut the golly why did they only care
about me always Lily finished there oh
this is going down
oh this is go whoa whoa finally they
plan something smart against me they're
so [ __ ] stupid
hey Jimmy why what's going on wow that's
really hot
what did you want oh hey
BAM stop crying Jimmy
I'll just keep shooting him
[Music]
good job back [ __ ] I have why was his
name
whoa nice go ahead nipple shot nipple
shot nipple shot yep
[ __ ] you [ __ ] sent this for my
girl that I don't even like and this is
for her not paying that much when I did
their [ __ ] quest it was pointless
Johnny you're just pissed me off your
face smells I don't even know how a face
smell I never ever met someone with a
face that smell maybe their breath but
not a face that's dry I told you I was
the dead got it yeah George you do what
I say all right I think give up you can
have her
whoo what are you talking about Johnny
Lola you win she's yours no one I don't
care you can keep that [ __ ] for yourself
what you don't want her then why did you
do this why'd you fight it was just to
prove you're tougher than me
Yeah right and don't you or your boys
forget it I'm tougher than you so maybe
now you'll stop bullying everyone you
work for me now man-bat [ __ ]
ride [ __ ] all right so now we
got the greasers I'm sorry gotten to
feel pretty good about myself
I'm just taking control of two of the
school's worst cliques but I know there
are bigger problems just around the
corner
problems with overdeveloped pituitary
glands and brains the size of peas
oh it's the job the thing is now that
I'm cool I'm not sure we can be friends
anymore what I'm messing with you
real funny Jimmy well when you're done
with this place a career on the stage
waits maybe maybe like a male stripper
or something huh what yeah hmm what what
about Gary
I have a son got busy but whenever I
hear somebody say I used to be a girl
and had a sex change or that my mother
slept with Crabble snitch to get me in
here I think to myself Gary well I guess
he's not always wrong
is that what you really think whatever
Jimmy you know I stand up for you and
you still think I'm a dork your jerk and
your equal whatever yeah I'm leaving yes
I go you're gonna try to kick our asses
now no I think I'll do that more
publicly whatever pretty boy you'll get
yours yeah we'll see about that
go have some fun in the communal showers
oh I just dropped my soap please pick it
up for me losers Petey get up I think we
found some new people to have some fun
with finally we have to mess with a jock
I love the jocks and a baby I gotta go
why Fred come on then
what the hell is damage wait hahaha I
wasn't me it wasn't me so the school has
changed again I like that I like when it
was like winter so now which question
should we do next Bros that one down
there yeah I so get picky hi
I am miss garbage ban Ben oh [ __ ] its
class maybe we should finish with going
to class
what the [ __ ] put that banana day don't
you see my Eiffel Tower
alright stronghold ass I may be a loser
but at least I could lose their friends
hang out with whatever we wouldn't let
you into our gang Pete because you're
weird weird look at you you've got a
weak bladder
hey algae I need some help I've got a
plan to take over those jocks come hey
Jimmy hey so what do you say algae us
help you yeah think of everything I've
done for you since I got here yeah
you're like a bouncer we're a bit above
helping people like you I mean get real
dumb pee stain now you need my help but
you have a peace thing damn well you
know what you got to do now don't you
what beg no get to Ernest he runs I
click with a rod of iron
you get him on your side and you got the
rest of the meeting out of the palm of
your hand
how by joining the trigonometry Club no
that would never work you gotta show him
who's boss
there's my love for trigonometry be late
I love I love wait Jimmy I've ever
can I come from once I know I don't I
don't know what it's called in English
you gonna miss it
who asked nerds about earnest
whereabouts where the [ __ ] is it where I
say where are Jack Juarez - Rygaard
well [ __ ] Rosen where Roger well right
yeah where are right guys
where where wow wow wow where are Russia
wha sorry it's not Batman alright
alright Prez it looks like pizzas out of
time for today I'll see you tomorrow
like a favorite of you enjoyed
perhaps a lot subscribe comment and I'll
see you next episode
Oh ba ba ba ba ba
[Music]
maybe my crazy awesome beaver
that's don't gorilla
[Music]